zone Europe sur sensation
[Musique]
bienvenue dans zones Europe sur Radio
sensation et sur tv78 cette semaine nous
partons au Pays-Bas un pays qui compte
17 millions d'habitants et qui est
membre fondateur de l'UE depuis l'entrée
en vigueur du traité de Rome en 1958
il y a des
et des bateaux qui font l'amour au
carrefour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui chantent les rêves qu'il est en et
je m'en vais faire un tour du côté de
chez soi revoir mon premier amour qui me
donne rendez-vous
[Musique]
et vous le Cher
nouvelle étape du projet Gira les
initiatives vertes en zone rurale nous
sommes en Frise tout au nord des
Pays-Bas c'est la plus grande province
néerlandaise une région très agricole et
très rurale
hello Théo Andrea bonjour vous êtes l'un
des autres de ce meeting donc Gérard au
Pays-Bas quel est le programme de ce
meeting
le programme est de montrer aux
nombreuses personnes qui viennent
visiter le nord des Pays-Bas les
infrastructures durables que nous avons
construites ici et comment nous le
faisons en particulier l'aspect sociétal
comment nous encourageons la communauté
à participer à accepter les changements
que nous menons
la communauté l'aspect le plus important
de notre travail nous allons donc
visiter une entreprise agroalimentaire
et une entreprise énergétique
sur l'environnement est-ce que la
transition écologique est une priorité
au Pays-Bas
c'est une grande priorité surtout depuis
le début de la crise énergétique dans
toute l'Europe
le changement climatique est un sujet
important donc nous investissons
beaucoup pour essayer d'atteindre les
objectifs des accords de Paris sur le
climat
et pour tenter de les atteindre plus
rapidement que l'objectif donné en 2050
en effet d'ici 2030 nous espérons faire
de grandes avancées pour atteindre les
objectifs des accords de Paris
thank you
zone Europe
voici une alternative au supermarché ici
on peut venir chercher un panier ou bien
récolter soi-même ses légumes des
concombres des poivrons ou encore des
tomates l'occasion aussi de recréer du
lien entre la population et les
agriculteurs je suis Bryan je suis
gardien dans cette jardin ici
alors le but de ce jardin c'est de
produire des légumes des fruits pour les
gens et nous on les vend direct aux gens
et pas seulement un pièce mais toute une
saison de légumes
ils sont membres de jardin on sait
toutes sortes légumes on a presque 100
types différents alors de tout du saison
oui c'est ça parce que à côté d'une
autre jardin on a une cobrative qui
permet les membres de acheter des
produits des autres producteurs locaux
alors nous on cultive les légumes de
forme de permaculture ça s'appelle c'est
une sorte de bio extra et on n'utilise
pas des
des produits
en Frise il y a plusieurs de ce type de
jardin et ça ça augmente c'est ça alors
ce type de jardin ça permet que les gens
aussi connais
les légumes ils savent d'où vient et
comme ça on fait une lien entre le
producteurs et les
consommateurs et puisse très nécessaire
parce que on a vraiment perdu cette
ligne ce jardin on peut calculer plus ou
moins une hectare une jardinier pays
mais à côté de ça il y a plusieurs
membres qui qui veulent venir aider
c'est bienvenu mais ce n'est pas
nécessaire c'est pas obligatoire
et en plus de nos jardiniers des fois il
y a des jeunes des différents éducations
qui viennent apprendre
être jardinier ou cultiver un jardin
comme ça
je suis le coordinateur du réseau des
villages durables grâce auxquels nous
partageons des connaissances notre
expérience est des idées nous avons un
site internet qui permet de partager nos
connaissances et de montrer au monde ce
que font ces villages
communauté
village de la région du friseland il
s'agit d'une communauté créée autour de
potagers en permaculture les légumes
mais les fruits n'ont pas besoin
d'apport en engrais et le sol est ainsi
protégé c'est une manière de cultiver
différentes sans apport de produits
chimiques et de très beaux produits dont
le goût est très bon ce qui est bien ici
c'est que ce n'est pas seulement un
jardin potager mais aussi une
coopérative alimentaire ici au Pays-Bas
il y a une tradition autour de l'énergie
coopérative dans notre cas on va
retrouver côte à côte les produits du
jardin avec ceux des fermiers locaux qui
peuvent mettre leurs production en vente
sur notre boutique en ligne
comme ça vous pouvez aller sur internet
et réserver vos produits le mercredi et
le samedi les fermiers apportent la
nourriture mais ce qui est vraiment
sympa c'est que nous travaillons aussi
avec des fabricants de produits bio et
vous pouvez choisir parmi 10 000
produits même des brosses à dents
all of the future
[Musique]
tout est livré avec le même camion ce
système protège nos agriculteurs locaux
car les gens font le choix de
s'approvisionner chez eux de choisir la
viande de telle ou tel producteur tout
ce qui n'est pas produit à l'échelle
locale et tout de même bio ainsi nous
avons notre propre système de nourriture
certes à petit échelle mais on compte
200 initiatives de ce type ensemble nous
travaillons en réseau et là on atteint
une taille importante
le plus important est de créer une
structure sociale dans le village on
commence toujours à l'échelle
communautaire car des gens qui jardinent
ensemble peuvent aussi contribuer à
protéger la planète c'est méconnu mais
l'empreinte alimentaire de notre région
est énorme du fourrage arrive du Brésil
pour les vaches les excréments sont
stockés ici et le lait est exporté en
Chine car nous l'exportons
ce système d'économie linéaire est en
train de détruire le monde il faut
absolument arrêter et être ouvert à une
autre façon de fonctionner ainsi nous
créons ici une économie circulaire c'est
une transition vers une nouvelle façon
plus durable de s'alimenter et nous le
faisons ensemble avec les habitants je
pense que la structure sociale défrise
l'Inde existe depuis 2000 ans car les
gens ont appris à construire les digues
ensemble pour protéger leur terre ils
ont l'habitude de travailler ensemble et
maintenant c'est juste un nouveau
challenge pour eux celui de
l'alimentation cela fait environ 10 ans
que l'on travaille là-dessus en lien
avec le défi énergétique qui est
étroitement connecté au défi alimentaire
en ce moment même l'augmentation du prix
des aliments étroitement corrélé avec la
hausse du prix du gaz depuis 30 ans de
nombreux villages de la région ont leur
propre éoliennes et leurs propres
production d'énergie et savent
travailler en conséquence par exemple
s'il n'y a pas assez de vent il n'y a
pas assez d'énergie et on ne traite pas
les vaches ce système d'économie
d'énergie est une réelle tradition ici
l'entreprise yelbelsma est spécialisée
dans la construction d'infrastructures
dans l'entretien des routes dans les
aménagements mais sa particularité des
panneaux solaires sont installés sur son
toit des panneaux qui apportent de
l'énergie à l'entreprise mais également
au village juste à côté madame
je m'appelle gel Belma et je gère la
compagnie qui porte le même nom
nous travaillons à la base dans le
terrassement et l'aménagement paysager
dans le nord de la Hollande
notre travail facilité par 4000 panneaux
solaires qui produisent d'électricité
dont les communautés locales ont besoin
nous avons démarré il y a 7 ans avec
environ 500 panneaux pour notre
compagnie un autre compagnie travaille
essentiellement en province
et c'est la coopérative locale qui m'a
posé la question
nous avons souhaité leur facilité la
tâche quand tu as une transition vers
l'énergie solaire
la production de panneaux solaires a
beaucoup augmenté en Hollande mais nous
sommes la compagnie la plus importante
pour l'approvisionnement des villages
nous ne pouvons plus en construire
davantage car le marché est actuellement
saturé dans le pays
2 ans nous produisons également de
l'énergie pour l'agriculture
à ce sujet car les gens pensent que cela
défigure le paysage de la campagne et
qu'il est préférable de placer les
panneaux solaires sur les toits et non
sur les terres cultivables directement
bonjour vous êtes donc députés
provincial de la frise et membre de la
cedea le parti de droite au Pays-Bas
alors pour la première fois cette année
les Pays-Bas ont un ministre du climat
et de l'énergie pourquoi est-ce qu'il y
en avait pas avant
c'était une histoire très difficile et
une histoire très difficile très
difficile
mais nous avons vu le changement
climatique partout au Pays-Bas et
particulièrement dans la région de la
Frise qui est en dessous du niveau de la
mer ce qui est très dangereux
si vous voulez prendre les mesures
appropriées maintenant au 21e siècle
vous devez travailler sur les problèmes
environnementaux
c'est pour cela que nous avons dossier
aujourd'hui dans notre agenda au
Pays-Bas et c'est très important pour
nous parce que c'est très important pour
tout le monde mais c'est difficile
quels ont été les premières mesures qui
t'ont qui ont été prises par ce ministre
ce nouveau ministre du climat et de
l'énergie c'était très important pour
nous que nous avons des projets qui qui
avaient succès
mais nous avons nos propres défis
géographiques ici nous avons énormément
d'eau alors nous aimerions tirer notre
énergie de cette ressource
project ce genre de projet c'est la
première chose que j'ai mis en place en
tant que responsable politique locale
mais nous avons d'autres ressources ici
nous avons beaucoup de vaches des vaches
ici parce que nous se sont très archi
culturels and make from that avec le
fumier on peut produire de l'énergie
ça sent un peu mauvais mais ça
fonctionne
les pays passent sont l'un des pays les
plus menacés par la montée des eaux
est-ce que c'est une réelle inquiétude
ici en frise et qu'elle qu'est-ce que
fait la région quelle stratégie sont
mises en place aujourd'hui déjà
oui
nous pensons que c'est très important de
mener les projets avec succès
que les gens réalisent l'importance des
enjeux climatiques les plus un choix à
présent c'est une nécessité
nous devons être sûr que les gens
étaient assez d'argent pour mettre en
place ces projets mais aussi nous
assurer que ces projets se concrétisent
réellement il ne reste pas de simples
projets sur le papier
quand vous regardez nos campagnes il y a
énormément de possibilités nous avons
l'espace le bétail l'eau ce n'est pas
comme en ville et nous ne voulons pas
être des colonies des villes
avoisinantes dans lesquelles les
habitants viendraient servir cela
n'arrive pas à par ici
zone Europe
les énergies renouvelables représentent
autour de 10% du mix énergétique
néerlandais plusieurs initiatives sont
développées comme le photovoltaïque ou
la quaternité
[Musique]
je suis membre du groupe de travail de
la ville de egg nous sommes un petit
village des Pays-Bas environ 2000
personnes vivent ici à côté d'un grand
lac
try nous essayons de sortir du gaz
d'être un village durable
nous travaillons sur un gros projet
prendre la chaleur du lac en été
l’enterrer profondément dans le sol la
chaleur restera là et en hiver on pourra
grâce à des moyens technologiques la
dotérer pour les maisons on aurait plus
besoin de gaz mais nous pourrons
chauffer les maisons grâce à la chaleur
de l'eau
nous avons déjà travaillé dessus depuis
quelques années ça a commencé avec
l'idée d'une personne qui a dit Hey
pourquoi on ferait pas ça et ensuite ça
a pris beaucoup de temps et des sorts
pour organiser le projet de trouver les
bonnes personnes car toutes les
personnes qui travaillent dessus
habitent dans le village il y a beaucoup
de volontaires mais ces deux dernières
années il y avait aussi des salariés
c'est un projet à plusieurs millions
donc on doit devenir des subventions
actuellement tout le monde a remarqué
qu'avec le gaz Poutine et ce genre de
choses il est difficile de faire une
bonne analyse de rentabilité et d'avoir
un prix stable
il y a donc beaucoup de choses qui
demandent des efforts pour changer
l'aspect technologie qui ne demande pas
beaucoup d'efforts par exemple au
Danemark beaucoup de fermes le font le
challenge c'est de le faire dans un
petit village avec toutes les maisons
qui ne sont pas forcément bien isolées
comment les chauffer grâce à la chaleur
de l'eau et comment faire sortir les
gens du gaz voudront-ils changer parce
que certaines personnes trouvent ça
difficile de changer
on fait beaucoup d'efforts pour informer
on fait des soirées des choses sympas
des choses plus sérieuses tous types de
choses pour communiquer
parce qu'on discute avec tous les
ménages autour d'une table de ce qui est
n'est pas un problème pour leur maison
comment nous pouvons les aider ce qu'il
considère difficile à changer et comment
nous pouvons les aider à obtenir une
subvention tous ces types de choses
je viens d'une région du sud-ouest de la
Frise j'ai de la communauté dans ses
projets de construction
[Musique]
ici nous avons un exemple de panneaux
solaires tous les projets sont portés
par la communauté en direction de la
communauté c'est ainsi que nous aidons
les habitants
c'est un super projet que nous avons
regardé
comment insérer dans cette région
particulière
toute l'énergie créée va à la communauté
par delà les frontières
[Musique]
la communauté a donc ses propres
panneaux solaires
ce qui implique dans le projet
[Musique]
le prix de l'énergie est très abordable
c'est en cela que ce projet est vraiment
spécial
et nous sommes maintenant avec Marc
miloudinovic bonjour bonjour vous êtes
donc secrétaire général adjoint de la
Maison de l'Europe des Yvelines est
conseillé municipal en charge des
relations internationales de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye vous êtes ici le
représentant de la délégation française
pour ce meeting JIRA au Pays-Bas
qu'est-ce que vous avez retenu de ce
meeting
plusieurs choses plusieurs choses très
intéressantes
au fil de l'eau de nos de nos visites de
nos discussions et des présentations que
nous avons reçues moi ce qui m'a
intéressé vraiment c'est que on a
rencontré des gens qui étaient
très à l'écoute des gens qui étaient
très
comment dire engagés dans les différents
projets concernant cette crise à la fois
climatique cette crise énergétique que
nous vivons tous
que ce soit quelqu'un qui fait de
l'agriculture avec de la permaculture
qui avec une centaine d'hectares avec un
hectare pardon peut nourrir 250
personnes avec également des des
coopératives de produits durables et de
produits en circuit court avec également
à l'opposé quelque part un industriel
qui est un grand
comment dirais quelqu'un qui fait
beaucoup de pollution il le sait c'est
son métier quelque part
qui a des solutions et qui proposent des
solutions alors ces solutions sont pas
forcément acceptées parce que comme
c'est quelqu'un qui doit faire une
entreprise il est obligé d'avoir des
prix qui soit dans les prix du marché
mais il connaît les solutions et l'idée
c'est que à terme les choses changent et
qu'on puisse adapter ces solutions qui
sont justement totalement réductrices en
termes d'empreinte carbone mais
effectivement faudra payer un peu plus
c'est à dire que en l'occurrence il
travaille avec les collectivités locales
il faudra que les collectivités locales
payent plus à contrepartie de quoi il a
installé un toit avec des panneaux
solaires qui fait que ces panneaux
solaires peuvent alimenter en
électricité une grande partie
de la ville ou de la petite ville en
laquelle il est donc cette cette façon
dont les les locaux se sont appropriés
les différentes problématiques et avec
différentes solutions ont permis
vraiment de prendre en charge tout ce
genre de choses je peux aussi parler des
personnes que nous avons vu concernant
l'énergie
le deuxième jour sur les panneaux
solaires sur la géothermie la quatermie
et ce qui m'a également frappé c'est
important c'est le lien et le comment
dirais-je les relations non seulement
étroites mais absolument indispensable
entre la collectivité et la collectivité
entre les les habitants et leur
structure
comme une municipalité ou comme ici une
province et ils sont dans une démarche
de co-construction c'est-à-dire que ce
n'est plus un état ou une ville qui va
imposer de base en haut un certain
nombre de choses c'est sur des idées des
gens qui vivent d'avoir comment
dirais-je des idées pour pouvoir vivre
mieux et vivre pour plus et ils font
remonter ces idées et à partir du moment
où celle-ci sont viables et comment
dirais-je suivre trois principes de
à ce moment là les collectivités se
mettent derrière et font le projet à
fond et ça c'est vraiment ce que
j'appelle une co-construction qui fait
que nous devrions tous
aller dans ce genre de choses on ne peut
plus maintenant gérer que ce soit une
ville un pays une région en Top Down
comme on dit tout simplement et puis la
troisième chose aussi
à laquelle je pense c'est qu'en fait il
y a cette espèce de sentiment à la fois
d'urgence mais également
d'intelligence écologique c'est-à-dire
oui effectivement on a des difficultés
oui effectivement on a une crise
énergétique une crise climatique
effectivement c'est bien connu mais les
solutions qui sont proposées sont des
solutions intelligentes concrètes
duplicable
bien loin d'un certain nombre de dogmes
qui sont parfois un petit peu exagérés
parce que vous avez relevé des
initiatives néerlandaises dont on
pourrait s'inspirer chez nous en France
parce qu'il y a des exemples à suivre
selon vous alors je crois qu'il y a deux
choses il y a une partie purement
méthodologique un petit peu c'est un
petit peu ce que j'expliquais en disant
il faut une co-construction c'est à dire
que on ne peut plus que ce soit une
collectivité que ce soit un département
que ce soit une région
imposées en 62 choses sans aucune
concertation et cette méthodologie de
discussion et d'implication de des
citoyens de nous de nous tous que nous
sommes dans des grandes décisions de ce
genre étant à mon avis quelque chose de
très important ce que j'ai retenu aussi
c'est qu'il y a des choses que nous
faisons peut-être déjà on le fait
peut-être à un niveau local à du niveau
d'une ville au niveau d'un département
mais on peut faire mieux bon
effectivement
quand il y a des panneaux solaires qui
couvrent tout un toit peut-être qu'on
peut trouver des des comment dirais des
building industriel qui permettrait de
mettre ces panneaux solaires alors avec
les toutes les contraintes législatives
qu'il faudrait peut-être qu'on fasse
bouger un peu donc voyez à mon avis il y
a beaucoup de choses qui existent que
nous avons aussi en France parce qu'il
faut pas non plus à ce flageller on a
quand même un certain nombre d'activités
mais peut-être qu'on peut aller plus
loin et et envisager d'autres pistes il
y a ces panneaux solaires alors le
problème des éoliennes enfin c'est c'est
une autre mais voilà il y a vraiment à
mon avis des ce qu'on a vu ici la
permaculture par exemple qui permet de
faire changer la mentalité des
agriculteurs
tout ça ça va peut-être prendre du temps
ça va peut-être prendre de la pédagogie
ça va nécessiter qu'on qu'on en parle
qu'on en discute mais c'est quelque
chose vers lequel nous devons tendre
voilà merci beaucoup mais avec plaisir
Marc millotino j'aurais été avec nous
[Musique]
allez ma famille
partons maintenant à la découverte des
scouts chier des bateaux typiques de
l'Afrique ils ont été construits entre
le 18e siècle et 1930 aujourd'hui le
scotch est Muséum retrace leur histoire
je suis Simon
je suis bénévole dans ce beau musée
nous avons 50 bénévoles qui gèrent ce
musée et ils ne sont pas payés
nous existons depuis
1998 ça fera 25 ans d'existence l'année
prochaine il y aura une fête par ici
l'an prochain
il y a eu de nombreuses constructions de
bateaux de ce type entre 1900 et 1950
maritime pour le transport de
marchandises
il y a 450 villages dans la région de
l'Afrique et la plupart d'entre eux
étaient reliés grâce à ses bateaux c'est
scouts
ils étaient aussi utilisés pour le
transport de nombreux objets denrées des
graviers des céréales
des abeilles sucrières et d'autres
choses encore
les bateaux étaient aménagés pour que
sur le pont
puisse habiter le skipper et sa famille
est parfois 7 à 8 enfants
avec plaisir
c'est un bateau typique de la frise la
plupart d'entre eux ont été construits
localement
zone Europe c'est terminé pour
aujourd'hui vous pouvez retrouver cette
émission en replay sur notre site
Internet et sur votre application radio
sensation nous on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]